Leo poesía continuamente,
escribo sobre ella a menudo,
y desmenuzo poemas
para ver cómo funcionan
porque soy una persona de letras.
Comprendo el mundo mejor, de manera más completa,
con palabras en lugar de, digamos, con imágenes o números,
y ante una nueva experiencia o un nuevo sentimiento,
me siento algo frustrado
hasta que puedo expresarlo con palabras.
Creo que siempre he sido así.
De pequeño, devoraba obras de ciencia ficción. Aún lo hago.
Y descubrí poemas de Andrew Marvell,
Matthew Arnold, Emily Dickinson
y William Butler Yeats
porque aparecen citados en la ciencia ficción.
Adoraba sus sonidos,
así que pasé a leer sobre la octava rima,
la cesura media, encabalgamientos,
y todas esas cuestiones técnicas
por las que te interesas si ya estás interesado en los poemas,
porque por aquel entonces, los poemas ya me hacían sentir
más feliz, más triste, más vivo.
Así que me convertí en crítico de poesía
porque quería saber cómo y por qué.
Ahora bien, la poesía no es algo con un propósito,
como tampoco lo son la música o la programación informática.
La palabra griega "poema" significa, simplemente, "algo elaborado".
La poesía es un conjunto de técnicas,
formas de hacer patrones
que expresan con palabras las emociones.
Cuantas más técnicas conozcas,
más cosas puedes hacer,
y más patrones reconocerás
en cosas que ya te gustan o te encantan.
Dicho esto, sí que parece que la poesía
sea especialmente buena para ciertos temas.
Por ejemplo, todos vamos a morir.
La poesía puede ayudarnos a vivir con eso.
Los poemas están hechos de palabras, solo eso.
Las particularidades de un poema son como
las personalidades que distinguen a las personas.
Los poemas son fáciles de compartir,
y cuando lees uno, puedes imaginarte
a otra persona hablándote o hablando para ti,
quizás alguien muy lejano,
o alguien inventado, o alguien ya fallecido.
Por eso, podemos recurrir a los poemas para recordar algo o a alguien,
para celebrar o para mirar más allá de la muerte,
o para despedirnos.
Y esta es una de las razones por las que pueden parecer importantes,
no solo para mí,
sino también para otras personas que no viven en un mundo de palabras.
El poeta Frank O'Hara dijo:
"Si no necesitan poesía, bien por Uds.",
pero también dijo que, cuando ya no quería seguir viviendo,
la idea de no poder escribir más poemas
evitó su suicidio.
La poesía me ayuda a querer estar vivo,
y quiero mostrarles por qué mostrándoles cómo,
cómo un par de poemas reaccionan ante el hecho
de que estamos vivos en un lugar, en una época, en una cultura,
y que en otra no lo estaremos.
Este es uno de los primeros poemas que memoricé.
Puede dirigirse a un niño o un adulto.
"Desde lejos, desde el crepúsculo y la mañana
y el cielo de los doce vientos,
la materia de la vida para tejerme
sopló acá... y aquí estoy.
Ahora — retraso mi exhalación
contengo aún el aliento —
rápido, toma mi mano y dime,
qué habita en tu corazón.
Habla ahora, y contestaré;
Cómo puedo ayudarte, dime;
Aquí en los doce cuartos del viento
tomo mi camino eterno". [A.E. Housman]
Este poema ha atraído a los escritores de ciencia ficción.
Ha dado pie a, al menos, tres títulos de ciencia ficción,
y creo que se debe
a que cuenta que los poemas pueden traernos noticias del futuro o del pasado
o de la otra punta del mundo,
porque sus patrones parecen querer contarnos
qué hay en el corazón de otra persona.
Cuenta que los poemas pueden unir a la gente temporalmente,
y yo creo que es cierto,
y se me queda en la cabeza no solo porque rima,
sino por cómo rima,
de manera limpia y sencilla en los versos 2 y 4
"say" [dime] y "way" [camino],
anticipándose ya en los versos 1 y 3,
"answer" [responderé] y "quarters" [cuartos],
como si el poema estuviese convergiendo.
Resalta el hecho de que morimos
exagerando la velocidad de nuestras vidas.
Unos años de vida en la Tierra
se convierten en un discurso, una exhalación.
Es un poema sobre la soledad,
el "yo" del poema siente que ninguna conexión durará,
y podría parecer una súplica de ayuda
hasta que llegas a la palabra "help" [ayuda],
y ese "yo" que está frente a ti, tomándote de la mano,
es más como un maestro o un genio,
o al menos eso es lo que él quiere creer.
No sería la primera vez que un poeta
escribe el poema que le gustaría escuchar.
El siguiente poema cambió mucho
lo que me gustaba, lo que leí, y lo que sentí que podía leer de adulto.
Puede que no le encuentren sentido si no lo han visto antes.
"El jardín"
"Adelfa: coral
desde los anuncios de carmín de los 50.
Fruto del árbol de tanto conocimiento
Castigar (la nada)
que puede ser besar o golpear.
Aparece
con vestimentas de usos desgastados
¿porque somos malos?
Gran amenaza masculina,
insinuante y coloquial". [Rae Armantrout]
Encontré este poema en una antología de poemas igualmente confusos en 1989.
Había oído nombrar a unos poetas,
los Poetas del lenguaje, que escribían cosas sin sentido,
y quería ver por mí mismo cómo eran.
Muchos no me llamaron la atención,
pero esta escritora, Rae Armantrout, sí lo hizo, y mucho,
así que seguí leyéndola hasta que sentí que entendía de qué iba,
igual que hice con este poema.
Es sobre el Jardín del Edén y la Caída,
la historia bíblica de la Caída,
en la que el sexo tal y como lo conocemos,
y la muerte, y la culpa surgen en el mundo al mismo tiempo.
Trata también de cómo las apariencias engañan,
cómo nuestra cultura puede arrastrarnos
a hacer y decir cosas que no pretendíamos o no nos gustan,
y el estilo de Armantrout intenta ayudar a parar o ralentizarnos.
"Smack" puede significar "besar",
como en lanzar besos al aire o besar en los labios,
pero también puede llevarnos a "smack" como "golpear",
como en la violencia doméstica,
porque la atracción sexual puede parecer amenazadora.
El rojo que significa fertilidad también puede significar veneno.
La adelfa es venenosa.
y los "usos desgastados", como usar "smack" para "besar"
o "golpear", pueden ayudarnos a ver
cómo suposiciones de las que no somos conscientes
pueden hacernos creer que somos malos,
bien porque el sexo es pecaminoso
o porque toleramos el sexismo.
Dejamos que los hombres le digan a los mujeres qué hacer.
El poema reacciona ante los viejos anuncios de pintalabios,
y su crispación sobre las afirmaciones,
sus inversiones y detenciones tienen todo que ver
con resistirnos al lenguaje de los anuncios
que quieren decirnos fácilmente qué queremos, qué hacer, qué pensar.
Esa resistencia es gran parte del significado del poema,
que me muestra, Armantrout me muestra,
cómo es oír graves amenazas
y una falsedad mortal en el lenguaje de todos los días,
y una vez ha hecho eso,
creo que puede mostrar a otras personas, mujeres y hombres,
cómo es sentirse así,
y decirle a otras personas, mujeres y hombres,
que se sienten tan aislados o amenazados,
que no están solos.
Ahora bien, ¿cómo sé que tengo razón sobre este poema tan confuso?
En este caso, envié a la poetisa un borrador de mi charla
y me contestó: "Sí, sí, más o menos es eso".
Sí. (Risas) (Aplausos)
Pero normalmente, no podemos saberlo. Nunca lo sabemos.
No podemos estar seguros, pero no pasa nada.
Solo podemos escuchar los poemas, y mirarlos, y suponer,
y ver si nos aportan lo que necesitamos.
Y si nos equivocamos sobre alguna parte del poema,
no ocurrirá nada malo.
El siguiente poema es más antiguo que el de Armantrout,
pero un poco más reciente que el de A.E. Housman.
"El hombre valiente".
El sol, ese hombre valiente,
acude por las ramas tendidas a la espera,
ese hombre valiente.
Ojos verdes sombríos
bajo formas oscuras de la hierba
se dan a la fuga.
Las estrellas virtuosas,
pálidas riendas y espuelas puntiagudas,
se dan a la fuga.
Temores de mi cama,
temores de vida y temores de muerte,
se dan a la fuga.
El hombre valiente asciende
desde abajo y camina sin meditación,
ese hombre valiente". [Wallace Stevens]
El sol en este poema de Wallace Stevens parece tan grave
porque la persona del poema está aterrorizada.
El sol asciende por la mañana a través de las ramas,
dispersa el rocío, los ojos, sobre la hierba,
y derrota a las estrellas, concebidas como ejércitos.
"Valiente" tiene el sentido antiguo "ostentoso"
y el sentido moderno "valor".
El sol no teme mostrar su rostro.
Pero la persona en el poema está asustada.
Quizás ha estado despierta toda la noche.
Esa es la revelación que Stevens guarda para la cuarta estrofa,
en la que "se dan a la fuga" se ha convertido en estribillo.
Puede que esta persona quisiese huir,
pero fortalecido por el ejemplo del sol,
quizás decida levantarse.
Stevens guarda para el final la palabra de sonido extraño "meditación".
A diferencia del sol, los seres humanos piensan.
Meditamos sobre el pasado y el futuro, la vida y la muerte,
lo que hay sobre y debajo de nosotros.
Y puede asustarnos.
Los poemas, los patrones en los poemas,
nos muestran no solo lo que alguien pensó,
o lo que hizo, o lo que ocurrió,
sino cómo era ser una persona así,
estar tan ansioso, tan solo, ser tan inquisitivo,
tan bobo, tan absurdo, tan valiente.
Por eso los poemas pueden parecer tan duraderos,
tan personales, tan efímeros,
como algo dentro y fuera al mismo tiempo.
La poetisa escocesa Denise Riley compara la poesía
con una aguja, un pedazo del exterior que alojo en mi interior.
Y el poeta estadounidense Terrance Hayes
escribió 6 poemas llamados "Viento en una caja".
Uno de ellos pregunta: "Dime,
¿qué haré cuando haya muerto?",
Y la respuesta es que él permanecerá con nosotros
o quizás no, no permanecerá dentro nuestra como viento,
como aire, como palabras.
Ahora es más fácil que nunca encontrar poemas
que puedan quedársete dentro, permanecer contigo,
poemas de hace muchísimo tiempo o muy actuales,
poemas escritos muy lejos o al lado de tu casa,
casi sin importar dónde vivas.
Los poemas pueden ayudarte a decir y mostrar cómo te sientes,
pero también pueden mostrarte sentimientos, modos de estar en el mundo,
personas muy diferentes a ti,
quizás incluso de hace mucho tiempo.
Algunos poemas incluso te cuentan que eso es lo que pueden hacer.
Eso es lo que hace John Keats
en, quizás, su poema más misterioso.
Es misterioso porque, probablemente, está sin terminar.
Probablemente lo dejó así.
Y porque quizás esté destinado
para un personaje de una obra de teatro.
Pero puede también que sea solo la idea de Keats
sobre lo que sus propios textos,
su propia escritura, puede hacer.
En este poema yo oigo, al menos yo oigo, mortalidad,
y oigo el poder de las técnicas poéticas antiguas,
y tengo la sensación, puede que Uds. también,
de, por un instante, conocer, casi convertirse,
en alguien de hace mucho tiempo,
alguien bastante memorable.
"Esta mano viviente, ahora tibia y capaz
de agarrar firmemente, si estuviera fría
y en el silencio helado de la tumba,
de tal modo hechizaría tus días y congelaría tus sueños
que desearías tu propio corazón secar de sangre
para que en mis venas roja vida corriera otra vez,
y tú aquietar tu consciencia — la ves, aquí está —
la sostengo frente a ti".
Gracias.
(Aplausos)